une salle le scarabée deux jours de
concerts et onze artistes pour une même
cause
là ils for humanity est organisée par
plusieurs associations yvelines one
tout simplement pour rendre hommage aux
victimes du terrorisme et surtout pour
alors pour faire voir à ceux qui nous
ont attaqué il ya un an et au 14 juillet
que nous sommes toujours là toujours
debout et comme dirait on est toujours
vivant des artistes français comme
d'alban îlots one is innocent ou encore
les fatals picards ont répondu à l'appel
des associations des groupes touchés par
les différents attentats terroristes etc
dans tous les concerts
y aura toujours un conte
avec un drapeau de retour ils ont perdu
leur azem lumière est un jeu sont donc
et au fait à quand un homme jardin donc
ils vont bien sûr voulu rendre hommage à
cette personne ne leur équipe c'est très
important pour eux et nous avons en
avoir une descente aussi qui était qui a
été très engagé suite aux attentats du
charlie hebdo qui a fait un clip qui a
fait une chanson
tous les bénéfices de ces différents
concerts seront reversés à l'association
aux victimes du terrorisme
deux jours de musique pour se souvenir